all these forms of resentment and uh you
know the idea that if men gain women
lose or if women gain men lose i'm very
critical of that that idea um but we've
seen all these discussions of like toxic
masculinity and
you know these sort of sweeping claims
about basically how all men are evil you
know and i i think this is like really
really unhelpful for everybody and it's
simply not true
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
philosopher social commentator and the
author of what do men want nina powell
welcome to trigonometry thank you
it's good to have you on uh look before
we get into the interview itself uh we
are obviously we've known you for a long
time and it's been a long time coming
you coming on the show but i've always
said to you when you finish your book
let's get you on so we know you very
well but for anyone that doesn't know
you who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that lead you to be sitting here
talking to us about this on camera uh
well i got the train
um but before that i was an academic i
taught philosophy at
the university of roehampton for 13
years and various other places i still
teach a bit of philosophy
largely to retired adults and also in
this brave new world of post or para
academia
which people are exploring now so people
just signing up for courses on anything
that interests them
and i'm very keen to break out of this
academic world and and you know
do things in that way so i left uh
academia maybe like three years ago two
and a half years ago and i write for
various publications including the
telegraph
and i
yeah i largely spend my time walking
about and thinking and reading
and writing and you are a very
thoughtful person and before we started
i was just
i we were chatting about some of the
controversies around your book and
things that we'll talk about and i was
just saying that like to me you just
like my lovely friend nina that i see
every few months and we have a chat
about philosophy or something else but
it turns out you're super controversial
and people are trying to cancel your
book before they've even read it and
stuff yeah no no well i think this is
quite a common experience now
particularly for women uh you know
particularly for women trying to think
in the public sphere and
um yeah i mean it's a crazy it's a crazy
crazy time and you know i was kind of
very involved in leftists and activist
politics particularly around the um
student fee increase so 2009-2010
in particular and i was very involved in
defending people who'd been arrested and
prosecuted and i would say persecuted
and at that point i think the left
understood who our enemies were right
like it was the state it was the police
it was the courts you know we were
fighting uh for free education um for
kind of universal access and all of
these sorts of things and then between
then
and now
something really weird happened and i
mean i think the left always kind of
fragments and turns on itself but i
think it did that in a kind of
turbocharged really deranged way
and it stopped really being about
compassion and discussion and
um solidarity and disagreement actually
and all of the things that
i remember of the left and you know
humor would be a big part of it and
actually lots of post-christian virtues
or christian virtues like
forgiveness and you know all these
things seem to have been kind of
abandoned uh in the sort of hyper
internet age and um
yeah so so i mean a few years ago now i
said something i was a member of the
labour party not particularly active
member but nevertheless i posted
something on facebook about how the
labour party seemed to be treating its
female members who were raising
questions about proposed changes for
gender recognition act with um total
disrespect you know they were being
interrogated and kicked out of the party
and i i was just like what's going on
this is like orwellian um
but um
and i posted that and i thought oh maybe
that'd be a bit controversial um but
that's how i felt you know i was just
sick of this stuff it's like you know we
should be able to discuss
everything particularly policy ideas
thoughts you know we do disagree like
that's the nature of humanity like it's
disagreement and we have to negotiate
that um and then yeah so i got kind of
targeted i suppose by sort of activists
and yeah lots of uh my i lost lots of
work i lost loads of friends um
i like when i give talks sometimes
people hire security guards to to
protect me in case anyone wants to
attack me uh yet the book people try to
preemptively cancel it without having
read it
by by emailing the
publisher and
yeah i mean uh like like lots of people
now i routinely get kind of called like
a fascist or a nazi or an anti-semite or
a terv or transphobia or whatever
welcome home yes i mean it's like you
know and it's it's obviously insane and
actually it's terribly disrespectful to
these words to misuse them i mean it's
like you know these things have a
historical specificity and a political
reality and you know i mean this is like
[ __ ] infantile sorry no no you you're
allowed stay
[ __ ] go for it no no it's like i
actually try not to swear in general i
think it like debases language but um
yeah anyway it's you you you know very
well i'm sure like the kind of guests
you haven't yeah so so this is where we
find ourselves so yes um i'm interested
in dialogue you know and i think that's
the only way we can kind of move forward
whether it's between men and women or
left and right or whatever what do you
what do you think the left isn't
interested in dialogue anymore yeah i'm
i'm not sure it's it's yeah certainly
turned its back on any kind of
philosophical aspect um
i think it sort of internalized the idea
that it's weak you know and and far from
understanding the fact that it actually
controls all of the
institutions um culturally at least
um it's sort of
it sort of permanently imagines itself
to be the underdog and therefore it's
okay because everyone else is the
oppressor so it doesn't matter if you
lie about them you know because they're
your enemy or
um this kind of thing but i don't know i
mean some people would say it's not
really what's going on it's not really
the left you know that it's something
else like because it certainly isn't the
left that most people i know who were or
are on the left
uh remember or feel that they're part of
like it's it's kind of lost its humanity
somehow it's a really good point because
they do love to dehumanize they do
love to use certain words
just a couple of days ago a labour mp
was being interviewed by julia hartley
brewer and she was asking him very
sensible questions about mask wearing he
was saying that he wears a mask she was
like what studies can you draw from that
proves that masks are effective and he
said something along the lines of well
we're not going to have any of this
anti-vaxx nonsense at the moment before
saying i feel the mask works
a sensible approach to wearing masks on
public transport and particularly a
sensible approach would involve evidence
that they made a difference have you
ever seen any of that evidence i haven't
i feel they've made a difference you
feel they've made oh well in that case
jonathan
i mean if that's if that's the way we
make decisions about people's freedoms
in this country if jonathan reynolds
feels they make a difference
i just feel throughout things like this
i know it's not your position but people
like me have followed the scientific and
medical advice and voted i'm asking you
for no no no
someone's saying you should do this it's
not the same as them producing evidence
how it affects my breathing and the
transmission of material from up of
course it's had an effect so look at of
course it's had an effect numerous
scientific studies have been done and
none of them have shown any significant
effect if any at all well i feel it's
been awesome
this sort of tedious anti-vaxx stuff
auntie excuse me
excuse me jonathan
how dare you how
dare you i am so fed up and so are my
listeners i'm asking you to produce the
scientific basis for you claiming that
you feel a policy works when it's a
massive infringement on civil liberties
and you've just basically accused me of
being anti-vaxxed i am double vaccinated
i have always encouraged people to get
the vaccination that is an outrageous
thing to say i am so fed up of that
yeah okay but this is just deranged you
know this is religious belief and that's
disrespectful to religion frankly
the thing is it's like if you want to
convince your uh enemy or someone you
disagree with of your position you have
to be able to argue it you know the idea
that you can just kind of like steamroll
your way for a conversation by repeating
mantras you know this is a cult like
this is not a rational dialogue between
adults right this is people who are just
kind of um
i don't know being insanely dogmatic you
know and and everybody's capable of
reason and thought and discussion like
this is what it is to be alive right and
and this way of being is extremely
unpersuasive it converts no one it just
reinforces the strength of feeling
within your own tribe and that's one of
the things i'm really interested to talk
to you about with your book is you're
trying to break out of the the sort of
dynamics and paradigms that men and
women have been put into in the modern
world
one very quick question before we get
into the book which is you talked a
little bit about how you think and i and
this is something on which i completely
agree by the way the women like you who
speak out against certain dogmas that
are now widely accepted on whatever we
call this thing that is not the left or
whatever
uh women are more attacked more they are
treated differently to the men and i see
this all the time right uh why do you
think that is i think there's this maybe
like a deep psychoanalytic explanation
um which is to do partly with i think
the idea that women should be
caring and kind and maternal and and you
know any woman who doesn't fulfill that
role is somehow some like sort of evil
witch or harridan and you know probably
should be burnt um but i actually think
a lot of people involved in this
activism are deeply deeply unhappy and
they kind of hate their lives and they
blame women for having even brought them
into the world you know so i think on
some level it's a kind of deep hatred of
life which then gets projected onto
women as they're kind of you know
somehow responsible for for nature and
for life so that's my my deep
psychoanalytic explanation that these
the people um who are really attacking
women kind of hate themselves and i
think in some cases actually envy women
in another kind of like very creepy and
disturbed way and i think these are the
kind of public conversations we need to
have
um about how men and women relate to
each other in terms of affection and
love but also the complicated aspects in
terms of difference and and possible
envy in some cases and things like that
well let's talk about your book because
you know it's really really interesting
in some of the stuff you look at and and
i do see that see it as an attempt at
synthesis right you're trying to bring
different points of view together so
first of all where do you think we are
as a society when it comes to men and
women and where would you like to see us
move to yeah i think and you know i
think it's always interesting i think
there's something kind of profoundly
beautiful and
uh always sort of thrilling about the
relationship between men and women
whether it's between individuals or
collectively
and it's always kind of shifting so i
think we live in a very mixed world i
describe it as like a heterosocial world
the fact that you know work and social
life and and
many aspects if not all aspects of
existence in the modern world are
basically um shared you know that men
and women do not really have their own
domains there isn't kind of um any form
of of of separation positive or negative
and that might be an issue it might be
that men and women need to spend more
time
apart
sometimes you know for them for the sake
of themselves and also greater harmony
um i think obviously i talk about after
me too
you know that whether that was a kind of
historical um
you know
whether that was always going to happen
at some point you know whether there was
a sort of
necessity um but also about the negative
aspects of that like at this world of
surveillance and technology and how easy
it is to kind of sort of defame people
and make claims about people
it's very impersonal and inhuman and the
kind of technology has sort of separated
us in other ways
and so i think we're in a in a sort of
interesting moment i think there's the
possibility of reconciliation which is
what i talk about forgiveness and
reconciliation
um
i think that men and women generally
enjoy spending time together like
whether as partners or friends although
it's often like fraught as well like
that's the reality but i think what's
being presented in the media or
increasingly in the last few years is a
very negative story about men you know
generalizations about men
you could say well people always
generally generalized about women before
like this is just you know correcting
the record but i'm very against this
idea of retribution or the zero-sum game
i think this is like this everyone loses
so all these forms of resentment and uh
you know the idea that if men gain women
lose or if women gain men lose i'm very
critical of that that idea um but we've
seen all these discussions of like toxic
masculinity and
you know these sort of sweeping claims
about basically how all men are evil you
know and i i think this is like really
really unhelpful for everybody and it's
simply not true it doesn't accord with
the reality of people's lives like the
fact that you know men and women are
friends the fact that they love each
other the fact that people care about
their families their fathers their
brothers the sons and so on um
so i really dislike this kind of idea
that there's something kind of
fundamentally wrong with all kinds of
masculinity which is the sort of liberal
story we've been fed in the last few
years
it's a great point because the
the story that we've been fed is that
men are inherently problematic
the moment something happens like that
awful case like the sarah everard case
they sort of framed it like men did this
and you're like no men didn't do this it
was one man
can you explain why that's so dangerous
to take an extreme case like sarah
everard and then extrapolate it to be a
reflection of all men yeah i mean i can
see the temptation i can see why people
do that um and i think it's
you know
basically what everyone wants to prevent
is male violence right like we're all
interested in solving this problem like
men are violent towards each other
they're violent towards themselves i
talk about male suicide in the book it's
a serious problem
um and they're violent towards women too
right so we know that men are
responsible for the vast majority of
violence the question is how do we
prevent this you know i don't think that
demonizing all men and saying that
they're evil is going to help i think
that's actually going to encourage uh in
a sort of self-fulfilling prophecy sort
of way um particularly when men are
seriously alienated
and atomized and i talk about incels and
um you know in a way try to explain or
understand or sympathize with their
plight if you so i mean again these are
these are groups of men who are you're
allowed to hate you know um with the k
with these very very extreme violent
horrific cases right we of course we
have to recognize that's what they are
um they are rare um they are something
we absolutely want to prevent at all
costs um
one of my suggestions in the book is
that men do need to think of themselves
as a as a class you know i think women
are very used to being treated as like
examples of a class like this kind of
woman or you know that women in a way
either because of i don't know for
social cultural or other reasons um
often feel like they're members of a
class or they're often positioned in
that way in a way that men are often not
necessarily like men uh maybe think of
themselves as individuals first and men
second or something like this and that's
fair enough i mean we're all individuals
too
um but so so i'm very interested in
those kind of mechanisms of like
mentorship and
how men can if you like um deal with
other men when they're when they start
acting in ways that were that are
problematic right so the the man who
killed sarah everett um had a reputation
right other other men in the police
force gave him names like the rapist
right they knew that there was something
wrong with this guy
um and they didn't prevent it because
they didn't kind of step in and
deal with it right if you saw what i
mean like if if there was a more
self-conscious way of thinking this man
makes the rest of us look bad or might
make the rest of us look bad then there
might be better ways of kind of
preventing these kind of horrific
um acts if you saw what i mean
and so it's a really complicated
question but i think it in the first
place it's like saying men are good and
men can be good and this is not
something that we're generally used to
hearing in the past few years
so there has to be like positive
masculinity you know so that men can
improve like women too right we can all
be better you know this is a not only a
christian idea it's a you know an idea
we should all kind of i don't know um
hope for right rather than think that
we're kind of doomed and that you know
men are inherently bad or something like
this
so yeah so i think
i do think men do need to look out for
each other more and this is part of what
patriarchy and responsibility is
actually you know patriarchy is not
um
stealing things and telling people what
to do it's actually taking
responsibility in a profoundly deep and
human way whether it's for children
whether it's for other men whether it's
for women
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get fifty percent
off of the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter access of easy that
tells you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and
censorship when you see
you know men being demonized and you and
you see you know people saying these
things on social media a lot of the time
it comes from from women and you think
but hang on a second you have a father
you must say brothers friends whatever
else the vast majority of them will be
straight women who at the end of it will
want a relationship
can you not see that that is not helping
us come together that's not actually
helping society become more cohesive
you're just being divisive yeah and i
think it cuts both ways you know there
are some men i talk about in the book
who see in in all women you know or they
let's say they have a bad experience
with one woman and then they kind of
generalize like all women are [ __ ] or
whatever you know and i think so we you
know the difference is nina i'm very
sorry to interrupt this and this is not
like defending that point of view at all
because i hate men like that but
they are a tiny minority none of that
and they don't get column inches right
you don't get to have an article in the
guardian every week talking about how
women are [ __ ]
i mean that would make for great a great
concept
yeah
do you know what i mean though like
that's the difference absolutely of
course so what i was going to say is
like you know you have a small number of
men who might say that there's a small
number of women who say generalize about
men in the same way right but
one of the things i say is that like
misogyny true misogyny is actually
really rare you know just as miss andrew
is actually really rare yeah because in
practice women
largely spend time with men they feel
safe with them they trust them they love
them and so on so
you know again it's this kind of like
getting away from this resentment
and this zero-sum game idea is like how
can we live better together you know and
acknowledge harm where it's necessary to
do so but not make these kind of
systematic generalizations about all men
or all women you know and i think me too
in some ways was this kind of really
unfortunate one of the aspects of it
that was really bad it it
people were allowed to sort of wreck on
previous relationships right probably
all of us have had bad relationships
where it wasn't particularly anyone's
fault it was just you know or it ended
badly or you know both people behaved
stupidly or whatever you know and
but some people wanted to then go back
because particularly some women wanted
to go back and say you know that guy was
a was an abuser or that guy was like you
know
evil
right because that whole victim
narrative allows you to do that it
allows you to see the world in black and
white but it's not right we're all kind
of capable of harm we're all good and
bad we're all a mixture of these things
men and women included and if we
position women as pure victims then
we're basically putting them back in the
position of being children right which
is not what women want either right you
know there's something kind of awful
about that so women do have power right
women do have meaning and agency and
they they can make choices and all of
those things um and they can also be
very um cruel to men you know they can
destroy men's lives if they want to you
know so i think we have to acknowledge
that both men and women have power they
have different kinds of power right but
what it means to be an adult is actually
navigating and negotiating those things
in all of their complexity and it's too
simple to say you know
either this group of people is good or
this people's group group is bad you
know it doesn't work like that well the
last question before you jump in
constantine is how much of this do you
think
is based on the desire for vengeance
i mean it's a particularly loaded
question i i remember with me too
seeing what happened when people were
talking about it and understandably
there was anger and there was rage
but there was also this very unpleasant
undercurrent of wanting to tear men down
that i've found really uncomfortable
it's why
i never really got behind the whole me
too thing because i knew where it was
going to end up i could see what was
happening i knew what the end game was
yeah i mean i think again like
psychoanalytically as a society we
haven't really confronted these things
like the desire for revenge or envy or
lust or you know these things are really
hard to deal with you know and and often
these things are kind of like cover
stories or eruptions for a deeper
conversation and i think well one thing
that's really important would be to sort
of have a more psychoanalytic discourse
in general you know and not pretend that
we're somehow past all that just because
we've got mobile phones you know and one
of the aspects of the book is like going
back to previous things that our
ancestors did and thought as if you know
i i hate this idea that we're modern and
that we there's nothing for us to learn
from previous ways of thinking or from
previous ways of behaving i mean there's
loads of stuff to learn in fact people
maybe had better solutions you know you
see these sort of young women on tick
tock for example going like oh you know
oh maybe we should get men to stay
around if they you know if we have a
child a child with them and you know
they should take some responsibility and
it's like you've just reinvented
marriage this is happening all the time
it's like there were previous solutions
to some of the same questions um but
yeah i think i think maybe there are
different ways of acknowledging these
sorts of deep currents like the greeks
had myth and gods and you know there's a
way of kind of dealing culturally with
psychoanalytically describable emotions
that don't go away you know just because
we're online you know so i think we
probably need a better culture
in a way that deals with or a culture
that basically acknowledges more
explicitly these complex feelings so it
doesn't turn into a kind of vengeance
spiral
yeah yeah because we do act like every
activist is motivated purely by the
desire to improve things when right
having met activists
yeah there's a lot of ego weird stuff
going on yeah there's a lot of there's
ego there's revenge there's bitterness
there's a resentment there's personal
trauma that's built on to make the whole
world seem like it's that thing
do you think one of the reasons that we
are sort of talking about this stuff now
increasingly and you know one of the
reasons i think for the explosion and
jordan peterson's popularity was the
fact that
maybe it's this narrative or maybe it's
other things you you tell me what you
think but we've kind of got to a
position over time where as francis
talks about we've demonized men and
we've said they're bad
but we've also created increasingly
generations of men who are not living up
to that standard of patriarchy the
positive vision of patriarchy you
described increasingly you see young men
taking less responsibility increasingly
not hanging around when they've had a
child with someone
you know abrogating other things that
men traditionally are supposed supposed
to do in inverted commas uh so at the
same time as telling men they're bad
we're also seeing men actually not
behave like men much anymore
yeah so i do discuss um peterson's
popularity in the book and
you know i think it's really symptomatic
i think it speaks to a need or a desire
for a father figure in the first place
you know like there's something
extremely patrician about pizza and he
dresses in a kind of 1950s dad sort of
way you know and he's sort of literally
telling people to clean their room and
stand up straight and all the things
that you would associate with a sort of
um you know father figure and and i
think his popularity has to partly be
diagnosed in that way that he's
providing something which isn't there in
the broader culture amongst other things
um and actually i mean i say that this
is good for women peterson is actually
good for women just because one thing he
says to young men in particular but not
only but let's stick with the young men
is you need to take responsibility for
your own life and not blame women for
your situation
and the implication is also like if you
sort yourself out then you might stand
more of a chance basically of you know
being attractive to others getting a job
and you know functioning in the world
and actually that takes the pressure off
in that sense you know the the idea that
men deserve a woman or it's woman's job
to tidy up after men or something like
that you know peterson's against that
you know so i think it you know whatever
he says about women who cares women are
chaos great fantastic
that's all fine but actually i do think
on balance he's actually very positive
in that sense yeah i agree you know and
the and it's the stoic virtues you know
like there's so much stoicism in the
kind of masculinist literature you know
and i think it's really interesting it's
very very um symptomatic and significant
i think well it's the only thing that
works for men this is why you know you
say for you know you you empathize with
themselves i empathize with them less
actually but i don't hate them yeah i
just think they haven't got the piece
that that that helps make your life
better which is as a man you've only got
really one route you work hard you
improve your skill set you get better
you make more money you raise your
status in society and then all the stuff
that you currently not getting because
evil women haven't let you have it
it's going to happen right but for a man
the root to that lies through taking
responsibility upping your game that's
it for a man right you've got to up your
game and that's it so being stuck in a
community of other people who encourage
you
to stay where you are
that's my issue with that movement only
i i empathize with with that yeah i mean
there's a strong class dimension too
which is um in alex lee moyer made a
very interesting documentary i don't
know if you've seen it um tfw no gf that
feeling when no girlfriend where she she
interviews um some incels who are like
big on um online and or people
associated with the movement and you
know this is really a story about class
like these are often young men living in
extraordinarily depressed and
dispossessed areas who actually yes
are trying to improve their lives
through working out through you know
laughing with their friends online and
so on but it's really really difficult
right when there's no jobs there's like
no hope you're stuck in your you know
the basement of your mother's house and
use a cliche but you know that is a
reality for millions of people and it's
like
i mean i don't disagree with you that
people have to take personal
responsibility um and i think one of the
problems with a certain
leftist or fake leftist discourse is the
idea that you can just blame the
structures you know that you have no
moral or individual agency or that
anyone who talks about individuals must
be right wing it's like no actually you
know you can't keep blaming society for
your problems yeah the reason i feel
comfortable saying it because it sounds
a little bit judgmental but look when i
was 18 i was sleeping in a park
right so if i can sleep in a park and
then still f make something of myself i
i'm not saying every single person is
the same or everyone should be like me
or anything like that but
if you find yourself in a difficult
position all i'm saying is i'm not
saying you will necessarily succeed i'm
just saying the only way out for a man
is that yeah there is no other way i
mean and to put it back in the context
of a community or relations it's like if
you sort yourself out i mean i've had
issues i had a massive midlife crisis i
was like told
totally messed up right and i sorted
myself out you know and i think a lot of
people have this experience at some
point right and it's possible and it's
amazing that it's possible and i think
the thing is like once you realize that
it's possible to take hold of your own
life it's actually better for everyone
else as well so it's not selfish to look
after yourself it's actually better for
everyone right you know because then you
can help other people if they they're in
trouble you know becomes this kind of um
outward-looking thing you know it's a
proper social gesture you know it's
actually much kinder and more empathetic
and thoughtful
um to to not be selfish not be a you
know self-indulgent prick you know but
isn't the problem
yeah but it isn't part of the problem
that the world that we're living in is
more and more feminized it's celebrating
more and more female values
you know the traditional male values of
traditional male jobs are dwindling
so
the problem is for men they're not
really getting a chance
to be masculine to celebrate these
masculine virtues and as a result
they're not progressing in the same way
yeah i think it's a this is a really um
important question and i think it's one
again that we all have to collectively
work out right in the coming years um
and there's been lots of interesting
articles and pieces about the kind of
feminization like i wrote a book in 2009
which was about feminization of work
um
so yeah i mean and it was an explicitly
political discussion
decision right so like under thatcher it
was like we are no longer going to be
this industrial nation we're going to
move towards the knowledge economy this
will privilege typically feminine skills
like you know communication and
mediation and and words and whatnot um
and yes i think that's absolutely
happened right so we live in an
increasingly feminized world however we
want to see that um
and it is a problem right there's this
kind of um excess of male energy and and
you know all of the ways in which that
would have been expressed through
physical labor i mean those jobs still
exist right it's not they're not
completely disappeared but you're right
there's a tendency you know it's like
i don't know if you go to kind of
depressed like um post-industrial places
a lot of men are working out in the gym
but they're not like working they're not
building things or making things you
know and i'm i'm pro people going to the
gym obviously but it's it's no
replacement if you like for actually
participating having a social role you
know and i think this is one of the
things that leads to the you know
sort of high rates of male suicide and
drug use and self-harm you know because
it's this lack of a social role
you know and i don't really have the
solution it's like you know we might
need to decide how to live together
differently in the future and what we do
with all of our different skills and
energies but it has to be a collective
decision and i think both men and women
of course and children have a stake in
this
it's a vicious circle we
um
we had dr tony sullivan and and the
first thing to be we did with him he
made such a profound point
remember if you're a boy you're going to
have you're likely to have mom at home
her friends then you're going to school
you're going to have a female teacher
in a the whole enviro you heart you you
hardly see a man i will give you
something that's really interesting you
can go to some of the some primary
schools now and it's happened to me on a
number of occasions
you go into the primary school and
suddenly
all these little boys start running off
running up towards you it's it's quite
it's quite scary it's almost like you're
santa claus you're going into it
and it's like oh man they haven't seen a
man yeah and they they think that they
secretly think you're going to be their
teacher that's it but they're
disappointing
because if you sit down with some of
those boys they actually do not have any
interaction
with any um
male 1
adult authority
yeah
none that's crazy
yeah i mean i do talk in the book about
the you know necessity for ritual and
mentorship and all of these things that
are kind of missing in our culture you
know i do i do think you know
children need both male and female
influence they absolutely do you know
girls as well um you know and of course
like we want to celebrate alternative
family arrangements and so on but at the
same time there's a general social
responsibility and i think um absolutely
am i speaking to someone today who is
saying that there's a australian
researcher who said that young boys need
to fight with older men like wrestle
with them so that the older man can tell
them when to stop if you so i mean so
that you learn your limits um and you
know what is appropriate and what isn't
appropriate in terms of your use of
physical strength you know and if you're
not getting that um
then the violence might go elsewhere
which is again what we want to deal with
what we want to confront and prevent you
know so
yeah really those kind of how to direct
all of that energy it's not being done
well and i think there is a suspicion of
men in mentorship roles sometimes that's
correct i think we also need to give
back power to female intuition by the
way so when women say there's something
not right here with a man like you like
men have got listen as well so i think
you know and and they've also got to
trust their own instincts and and what i
said before about men looking out and
looking after each other i think rather
than seeing themselves as this kind of
um first-person shooter individual you
know it's got to be a kind of um
horizontal relation to to masculinity
and to other men as well so i think we
all need to yeah participate in this
kind of um
i don't know
more harmonious and um expansive uh
relation that has more male and female
influences and also older people as well
like the way in which we treat older
people as if they're kind of irrelevant
you know
i think this cutting off of the older
generation um
you know from grandchildren and from
their children is also like
you know
awful it tells you something terrible
about our culture what you're talking
about i think is the atomization of
society just generally it's like we the
the size of the family shrinks the
number of connections people have
shrinks outside of their phone etc
there's so many things you're bringing
up so how do we get to the sunny uplands
of tomorrow where we're all living in
perfect harmony
i don't know about perfect harmony but
i think just a kind of more honest
discussion you know in general like not
demonizing one sex or the other taking
responsibility for ourselves and each
other um i mean acknowledging harm where
it exists you know and that's important
but also not thinking of ourselves as
kind of wholly good or wholly bad even
you know both are extreme positions that
are largely not true you know for
anybody
do you think we'll ever get past i mean
you're not the first person to have said
there's words sitting in that chair we
had julie bindle on a few weeks ago
and she talked about it and i think it's
inevitably a fact that
all of this conversation as you've said
earlier is about
dealing with the fact that men are
violent
right
do you think we'll ever get past the
biological reality that men are what
they are and women are different and
there's a size difference there's a
strength difference there's there's a
brain difference men are violent for a
reason right young men seek status and
and and in the process of doing that
that's when that happens
sure i mean we're animals with a thin
veneer of poetry right you know so and
and men and women are different i mean
this is like i make this point
i know now i can see why they're trying
to cancel you nina i know so my opening
line is like men and women exist you
know this is my controversial statement
um no and it's really important to
recognize where that difference is
relevant whether it's biologically in
law in sports you know in separate
spaces and so on right a lot of you know
discussions about this in recent years
you know but they are but we are
different and the difference i i want to
say is beautiful like it's cosmic you
know it's a metaphysical difference um
and it's it's what makes life with worth
living in many ways that i you know i do
discuss separatism that's one
possibility but i don't think that's the
solution it's certainly not the solution
for most people who will have a
relationship of one kind um either
friendship or you know at work or
whatever or a romantic relationship um
so it's i don't know i had to put it
like
that to recognize the capacity of men in
particular towards violence is there are
ways of channeling it like through sport
through um activity through kind of um
i don't know ritual and and if we
recognize it rather than
i don't know just sort of um pretend
that men can somehow be completely
different and change it's like to
recognize that reality and to channel it
in more positive and beautiful ways
you know right that's the only way
they yeah completely agree that is the
only way
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one-on-two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
there is the other part of it where
there is always unfortunately going to
be a small minority of men who are
sexually violent and i see some i'll see
these posts go up all the time after for
instance there everyone but also other
awful awful cases the the last one was
it was the awful case of that primary
school teacher who was murdered and you
and you see women write you know why is
it that i have to walk down the streets
and be scared of men and always looking
over my shoulder
and i think to myself there's a really
small part of me that thinks to myself
unfortunately there's always going to be
that small very small percentage of men
who do that
and they're always going to have a
disproportionate effect on society isn't
there
well i mean there are different ways i
think of of of preventing
i don't know how to put it it's not on
women to change their behavior i would
say i completely agree you know and we
live in
you know particular ways women have
particular freedoms i don't think people
would want to go
um towards a a more segregated or
domestic public private split in which
women stay at home or they need a
chaperone or whatever you know i don't
think that's what anybody wants um if
they do want that they can move
somewhere else um so but it's not about
sorry chinchilla just on that point
because this is you know francis says i
completely agree i don't completely
agree
i agree that women should have the
freedom to do what they want or everyone
should
i also don't agree that you're going to
get to a place
where a man and a woman can walk down
the same street at the same time of
night and be equally safe no it's not
going to happen right and if that is
true that means that yes unfortunately
as a society we have to be honest and
say
that is never going to happen because
there's a biological difference between
men and women and because men want from
women what they don't want from other
men by and large right in that sort of
environment and so we're going to have
to
you know yes we're going to do
everything we can to civilize men and
that's an important part of education
and upbringing whatever there's also a
part of civilizing women in the sense of
going like look you're living in society
and some people in the society are evil
and you need to protect yourself and
that may mean that you don't walk around
at 3am even though i can yeah sure i
mean that's probably the current
situation they're in i mean i do think
there are ways of kind of um
we condition ourselves right so i'm i'm
very against the widespread availability
of pornography right i think it's
extremely detrimental to men in
particular i think it changes people's
brain chemistry it does terrible things
to their thoughts i think it kind of
destroys imagination i think it kind of
um
courses and erodes our capacity to be
playful and and light-hearted actually
and i i think you know it
those sort of images are are horrific
you know i think they generate a vision
of the world which is um
you know very dangerous actually and so
i side with the kind of anti-pornography
feminism increasingly you know and it's
it for me it's it's complicated because
you know i also want to defend
experimental cinema and freedom of
expression and you know
um but we i think we have to look at the
material reality and if it turns out
which i think it does that pornography
is detrimental to the way in which
people behave in the world particularly
men um then we might want to have a
question about whether it's great to
have what such widespread availability
of hardcore pornography particularly for
younger people you know it's so that
would be one question you know we the
other side of it might be something
about how do we change our virtues and
our morals and how do we behave in a
more civilized way um such that maybe we
we we do go backwards in a certain sense
like towards traditions or uh modes of
social um interaction that are more
formalized you know so that we don't end
up having like um a million hookups that
are meaningless or something like this
you know is that really what the end
game of liberalism is like the freedom
to treat everyone like a commodity you
know i mean this is like really
disturbing you know in that way we
destroy everything that's like specific
about ourselves you know and we are
these like
you know i don't know beautiful
individual people
you know but by treating everyone the
same by treating them as someone to
consume we kind of destroy that
specialness
yeah i see what you're saying but come
back to my point about safety on the
street because i do think like
the the reason i'm bringing it up is i
know it's super controversial and i'm
interested in super controversial things
and i was just putting an argument to
you but to maybe give you a better
example
sophie our video editor he works with us
you know she used to come to a previous
studio which was not in a nice area and
every time she stayed late we'd either
get her a taxi which we wouldn't do for
a guy or one or several of us would walk
to the tube station and she always
really appreciated both of those things
but there's there's also an argument
which is sometimes being made when these
conversations are brought up which is
like well a woman shouldn't have to be
protected or a woman shouldn't have to
take a taxi and no in principle i agree
i just don't know given the sex
differences and male violence and all of
that that we've talked about that you're
ever going to get to a place where i
would teach my daughter
yo you can just walk around anytime
you'd be fine there's no [ __ ] way i'm
teaching my daughter that yeah no no
because that's irresponsible parenting
if you ask me right now some of the
feminist movement would say well that's
accepting the blah blah blah well yeah i
am accepting the reality i don't want my
daughter to put herself in positions
where she's going to be assaulted do you
see what i'm saying yeah no absolutely i
mean you know from a from a realistic
reasonable standpoint yeah i mean this
is how we behave right you know we we
look after people
um particularly women you know like
women are free to go and get drunk and
get high right then you would look after
somebody who was in that state you might
look after a woman
more than you might look after a man
right there are differences there are
physical differences there are
difference in levels of desire some men
are not going to um adhere to the social
rules i agree with you i i think in this
world as it currently exists it makes
sense to protect women more in certain
situations
but nina don't you think that it's
always going to be like that that's what
i mean there's always going to be that
percentage
right of awful people of all of awful
men there's always going to be abusers
there's always going to be rapists
unfortunately you're advocating very
hard on their behalf here
the action doesn't help i realize that
and
that's unfortunately going to be a
constant through society these crimes
have always just there's like there's
always going to be murderers just
so these crimes have always existed and
they will always continue to exist as
far as humanity goes well how do you
think men should
deal with that question
with what question specifically well
with this kind of inevitability of male
violence and of the amenities
inevitability of male violence it's by
men protecting women right to it so they
ensure that they're not walking around
so for instance you know
you've ended that sentence on a very bad
note
to ensure they're not walking around
making sure they stay no
to make sure that they're not walking
around at night and you know two o'clock
in the morning to ensure that if you're
in a dodgy area that they're going to be
taking a cab etc etc a bit of common
sense and whilst the utopian and me
would
want to get to that point there's a
realist in me that goes these crimes
have always existed they will always
continue to exist we have to protect
women from a very small percentage of
men and also to your earlier point if i
may answer the same question as well
about
the guy who murdered sarah everard and
who had a reputation the problem is i've
never been in that position where i i
thought or this person i'm working with
is a massive rapist like but i've worked
in the comedy industry might that's true
and yeah good point i take that back
i've worked in an industry with almost
everyone no um
but my point is
what are you supposed to do in that
situation as a man beyond protecting the
women who may in the immediate
environment be affected and going look
stay away from this guy or
you know keeping him away from them or
whatever but beyond that what is a man
supposed to do you can't report someone
because you think they might be a bit
dodgy
and we don't live in that society right
yet uh
like what are you do you see what i'm
saying i i don't think every problem in
life is solvable in that way
no i mean again i think it's really like
a very complicated question and i you
know i'm not here to say how men should
deal with other men i just think that
they should think about it yeah you know
and work it out you know i think there
might be forms of uh male violence that
might be necessary actually between men
you know uh absolutely or something like
that or the threat of it the threat yeah
this one i've always said this the
threat of violence is a really important
behavior modulator for men the fact that
if i behave in a certain way i'm going
to get punched in the face really
affects how i behave
right
so you know it's it's i think it's it's
not up to women and i
you know i
i agree it would be lovely to live in a
utopian world in which we didn't have to
worry about these things i think it is
always potentially a problem the the
trip would be to minimize it to kind of
yeah i mean i think we have to be
realistic i don't know if my book is
tough enough on men in some ways right i
think the darkness of some aspects of
male desire um is something that maybe
men need to talk about more you know
like what is it like to be part of a
class um that has these members in it
for you you know i mean
can you put yourself in the mindset of a
rapist or a murderer
no because
we interviewed luke guitos who is a
lawyer who deals with a lot of these
particular a lot of these particular
crimes and he says that actually he made
the point that rape isn't
about sex it's about violence it's about
control
so no i i i could never do that but i
unfortunately
acknowledge that these men do exist
and that is a darkness
to male sexuality but i don't see myself
as part of a class nina this is a thing
it's like i don't think that just
because someone has a penis and i have a
penis we're like the same thing
i treat people based on what they think
and how they behave and there are women
and men
who are like that and there's also women
and men who i just think are completely
alien to me so i don't see myself as
part of the same class
but the class has differences within it
right i mean if we want to say that sex
is real sex exists you know there are
men and there are women right yeah and
okay to the degree in which you identify
with that class is is kind of up to you
yeah um but you are a man yeah thank you
last time i checked no i am a man but
why does i what i don't understand about
that way of thinking is
why does the behavior of a tiny minority
of men who are different to me in every
way
reflect on me
well i mean if there are women who
behave in ways that you would disagree
with completely think abhorren and you
criticize openly
is their behavior reflective on you
because you're both women no but i think
there is a way in which i don't know
maybe this is
part of sexual difference maybe women do
identify with other women actually in
ways that men don't identify with other
men i think that's probably and i think
it's probably not just because women are
often treated as a class and women are
treated as examples of their class right
i mean this is de beauvoir's point in
the second sex you know women are in a
way
more often treated as members of the sex
in relation to men
and in relation to each other whereas
men in a way get to be individuals first
and foremost so you can say i don't
relate to these men i can't understand
these men who do these terrible things i
nevertheless admit that they exist and
they'll never go away or you know
um so i don't know i mean this is maybe
the provocation it's like as an
imaginative exercise you know to think
about what it is to be a member of a
class with people who you who do things
that you find absolutely abhorrent and
can't but to me their behavior rules out
their membership of my tribe
so they're not men no it's
because my tribe is not men my tribe is
people who behave and think in
particular ways
and a lot of them will be men but i'm
not i'm not
i'm the difference between me
and you
is far smaller than the difference
between me and ian hundley
far smaller the difference between you
and i far smaller i can imagine some of
the ways of being the way that you are i
can't imagine being in hundley
so that's that's why i'm saying what i'm
saying sure
do you see what so to me the maleness of
that situation is completely to me
they're a class of their own people who
behave in that way and
99.999 of men that i know would never in
the million years behave in that way or
even contemplate it yeah exactly and i
think we have to like be very um
make this point most men don't do these
terrible things right this is why it's
stupid to generalize about men and say
that all masculinity is evil and so on
right there but you asked about how do i
feel being part of that class that's
what i mean no no absolutely so i think
you know it's
it's really i don't know maybe it's a
kind of deeper question about the
problem of evil but we do
you need to see it more theologians on
your show but um so yeah i mean it evil
is inerradicable you know we live in a
fallen world you know satan is the
prince of this world um you know we we
do live in that way and i so okay
another preventative way of thinking
about it might be
how do we stop these small number of men
thinking that it's okay to behave in
this way or to treat women in this way
right
um
you know is it that they just they
disrespect women is it that they were
taught not to to kind of um
uh treat people in a certain way like
what's going on with that like why
i don't know how is it possible for them
to even be in this position that they
think it's okay to behave in this way
right
do you not think that that is a brain
thing like these people are sociopathic
their brain works differently um
because of childhood trauma because of
genetics potentially because all of us
carry rapist dna in us by the way right
every single human being on earth so
some i mean i'm not saying every single
person who's ever committed sexual
violence is like that but a lot of the
people particularly with the more
heinous stuff i think
uh
i just think that brain works
differently and there's been a lot of
evidence like if you look at psychopaths
and prison there's been a lot of studies
that show
they don't respond to the same incentive
structures as as
normal people
so
the reason that they do what they do is
they feel entitled to have what they
want to have and they don't care about
other people that is the definition of
sociopathy yeah right so
this is what i find so incredibly so i
was going to say offensive just
stupid about the narrative about this
issue is like you're not going to
educate these people to respect women
this is not an issue of respect for
women these people don't give a [ __ ]
about any other human being on earth
they care about fulfilling their desires
right and it is every man's desire to
have sex with a woman right so they're
going to do it
that's it and so
i don't think you're it's not an
educational issue no okay but let's say
those people who aren't sociopaths right
they're there there's a range of
behavior and a lot of the stuff we're
talking about actually is gray area
stuff right you know when people make a
mistake or they overstep a mark i mean a
lot of um things that are often treated
as very distinctive forms of um behavior
are actually much more complicated you
know they are people are making a
mistake or being drunk and behaving
inappropriately as we all have at some
point right let's let's be clear so when
we're talking about sociopathy i think
right it's a very it's extremely
difficult right how do we treat people
who in some ways we don't regard as
human in a way that doesn't itself fall
into the trap of inhumanity right
because
it's it's kind of almost unanswerable
you know you could basically say like
let's try and identify who these
sociopaths are before they do
sociopathic things i've seen that
minority reports a good one right
it might be possible
you know pre-crime
um
you know i i think uh you know we need
to talk about kevin the lionel schreiber
book is is sort of about this it's like
you know there are ways that i'm sure
people are working on you know how do
you identify it it seems like sociopaths
often have a trajectory like they when
they're children they kill animals or
whatever you know i i don't know enough
about it but it's
you know what if there was a way of
saying look there's something sort of
wrong from the standpoint of our you
know normal empathetic humanity with
these people we shouldn't treat them
inhumanely but maybe there's a way of
dealing with this with this question you
know and we know for example that seems
like
some sociopathy is quite useful like if
you're a brain surgeon or a pilot and
you you need not to have adrenaline you
need not to be squeamish you know
you you don't want someone freaking out
in those situations right
or empathizing with the brain in front
of them um so and you know you might say
well lots of our leaders are sociopathic
they behave in ways that are completely
uh inhumane and uh and look how great
everything is
right exactly so i mean again
collectively you know it's because we
live in such a fragmented atomized way
if we you know it's the same with the
women walking home at night if you live
somewhere where you knew everybody and
everybody's safety was part of a kind of
common project or everyone was looking
out for each other and you knew who
everyone was it would be a different
story
you know you might be able to identify
the person who is like potentially
dangerous and and deal with it or you
know i don't know the village elders
might be able to sort of say you're
behaving terribly or i don't know like
okay that's naive
but there are different ways of
imagining a social life which would
minimize harm but also not end up in
this kind of like pathological pod world
where everyone is just on their internet
because they're scared of going outside
which is what's been encouraged in the
last two years you know so there is a
kind of like to be alive is to to risk
right you know it's it's um
life doesn't really mean anything if
it's just safety and comfort you know
and you never take any uh risks at all
like that's just not living but and
that's what incels do that's what a lot
of men are doing and it's such a
profound point because they're
retreating they retreat into the world
of
internet you know forums or whatever
else or video games but what is a video
game but a chance for you to be able to
achieve
and that must be so tempting for
you know a young man who doesn't feel
that he has opportunities open to him
for whatever reason he can go into this
make-believe world and become something
it's also a very linear reward structure
as well which makes video again like i
play video games and enjoy them the
thing with the video game that's very
different to life is in a video game if
you work hard you will instantly be
rewarded like if you do the right things
you'll be rewarded in life you might
have you will be rewarded but maybe 20
years from now
if you do the right thing and you might
even be initially punished quite badly
as you found in your own experience so
that's the difference i mean yeah i mean
these are bigger questions about the
relationship between the real and the
virtual and the kind of
world we're heading towards right i mean
my book is is very critical of
technology it hates it you know it's
basically like we need to be together we
need to have real experiences real life
you know i there's a horrible image of
the world which says uh you know in the
near future only the elites will be able
to have real experiences real sex real
food real encounters real conversations
and everyone else would be like
[ __ ] you know wired up to
these sorts of things right
and this is terrible right we need to
break with this
thing that's coming you know and that
will involve men and women talking to
each other and you know being in risky
situations i mean even the dating stuff
it's like the idea that you can get the
algorithm to choose your date for you
rather than have a conversation with a
stranger in a bar like the idea of a man
going up to a woman now is like in in
work or in a bar is like really frowned
upon you know but that was the reality
like when i was growing up you just go
to the pub and get drunk and get off
with someone you know you wouldn't like
check out their feelings about the death
penalty
yeah and and it's also as well you see
these hashtags and like never data tory
right and you just go what you don't
want to talk to people who are different
to you exactly but no one does anymore
right but that's where the magic happens
to go i think you're wrong what happened
to a bit of sexual tension i didn't know
you felt that way about me mate
no i mean yeah totally totally i mean
like i don't want things to be mediated
in this this way so how do we get to the
sunny uplands nina this is what i want
to hear from you how do we how do we
heal all this because one of the points
you made actually i totally agree with
like my wife has like a card she can
pull out at any time if she says my
intuition tells me that we shouldn't do
this like it doesn't matter what it is
i'll just go
cool yeah and i'll accept her with that
argument because she's been proven right
on a hell of a lot of stuff in the past
so
intuition i think is a huge part of this
actually and intuitively men and women
know a lot more about the right way to
behave with each other
than what we're being told by society or
whatever right now do you know what i
mean so that's part of it what else how
do we get to this beautiful place in the
future i don't know i don't i mean my
book is optimistic it's not delusional
there is no like all right we're fun
no but i mean it's it's i think it's all
of these more delicate things you know
it is like playful conversation it is
acknowledging the reality that we do
have a whole series of you know
ambivalent and interesting relationships
with each other we have male and female
friends you know
it that these are not always over
determined by
by sex or by you know that that actually
we live in a much more sort of
complicated network you know if we're
lucky to have different social
interactions and i think yeah to be in a
position where those things are real and
possible you know so that there is more
conversation there isn't this kind of um
pushing people to the periphery and the
outside and saying you know oh no you
want a girlfriend how horrific like you
must go and you know play your computer
games forever i mean this is like um
sort of abnegation of our humanity you
know or to to say to men who are
depressed you know oh
suck it up i don't know maybe that would
work in some some cases right but
looking at the male suicide rates like
something's badly wrong here right this
should be a matter of concern to all of
us
you know it's not great for women either
that men feelings are feeling suicidal
right it's terrible
you know and i think this thing about
social role everybody sort of wants to
feel recognized they want to feel a
certain belonging they want to have a
kind of mixed and interesting life
and it sort of depends on all of us you
know
i think more more conversation more
listening
i don't know nice
gentle things one thing that i find
[Laughter]
nice gentle things
one of the things that i find
particularly worrying and i don't think
we talk enough about is
when you look at the younger generations
you know people in their 20s
they're not having sex
and that's really worrying
really really why why does it worry you
i mean i i yeah francis why does it
worry it worries me because it shows
that the sexes are further apart than
ever before it shows that we're not
connecting
but i mean the kind of sexual revolution
is what like 60 years old now and
i mean that's that's also a relatively
novel way of behaving with each other i
don't necessarily think having hundreds
of sexual partners is good for anybody
but then i also don't think it's good
for people to be virgins until their 30s
which we're starting to see now
i i think it's very very complicated
question it's also the question of
whether people are going to have
children or not you know which is also
there's increasingly kind of antenatal
narratives i you know marriage is
relatively unpopular
you know these are kind of um
are also things that need to be
discussed i i i don't know on the sex
question i i think
i do think sex is an interesting form of
communication it doesn't have to be with
the same person for you know forever um
but i also think at the other end this
kind of treating people as as
commodities you know there's actually a
fear of intimacy at the heart of lots of
um random sex you know that actually
what's not happening there is a kind of
um real relation with somebody else in
their in their uniqueness
you know that actually sex just becomes
something like a deliveroo you know so
my friend hadn't uh
asked his his phone asked if he wanted
to link up grindr to deliveroo you're
like
that sounds like a great night this is
very disturbing yeah it is it is right
you know that that you just sort of call
someone like to your house and and you
know it's like ordering a pizza i mean
there's something kind of i don't know
maybe i'm old-fashioned but slightly
it's ironic that in the world that
that's we all three i think would agree
is becoming feminized actually the
sexual marketplace is becoming
extraordinarily male
serving that that is how a man thinks of
sex
press a button it arrives
that's how a man thinks of sex
sorry nina
did it as far as i understand it on the
apps like it's something like 20 of men
get 80 percent of women right so that
actually it's not true that this works
out for men for some men it works out
for some men but what i mean is the mode
of thinking about sex is like that i
don't think most women think about
in in in the traditional sense would
think about
that whole process as being that way do
you see what i'm saying no and again
this might be a difference we need to
recognize you know like maybe there's a
way that marriage civilized men i think
it does i think women civilized men i
think men
i don't know they do 100
civilized women in a strange way or
maybe they're animalized women i don't
know but let's talk about it it's
complicated you know marriage was a
social technology that served a
particular function right and that was
good for children in general right i'm
not saying all marriage is great i'm not
saying all families are you know without
problems there are lots of issues in
particular instances but it did address
this problem which is men's desire for
sex okay yes you have to have sex with
the same woman maybe the french solution
you can have a mistress that's fine but
you know what i mean like it it kind of
um
it it contains it in a way you know and
i think this market the marketization of
everything
is not the right way to go in you know
the marketization of sex the
commodification of human bodies
is um
is anti-human it's what the elites want
and i don't think it's what most people
want even even men who say they would
like a lot of sex i think in the end
it's an empty and hollow process and i
talk about rush bee in the book who is a
pickup artist who's become very
religious and he's absolutely turned his
back on this kind of
pickup artistry thing because it's
completely empty at the end of the day
what's the point in tricking women into
having sex and having sex with hundreds
of women right what does that actually
get you you know it's
momentary satisfaction it's not real i
mean it's it's
not meaningful and it gets you a lot of
emptiness too right
and i
completely agree with all of that but i
think we skip past the point that it's
very worrying that young people
aren't having sex because it means
they're not having relationships and i
don't know any man who would be happy
being a virgin until he was 28.
maybe a small percentage might be but i
think if they're deep down i think
they'd be they wouldn't be happy about
it so many jokes
well i don't know i mean if you think
about kind of more traditional
arrangements it's like until a man got
himself um a job and had some sort of
status then he wasn't able to kind of
ask women to marry him you know
there's not necessarily anything but
that would also happen much younger as
well um potentially but lives were
shorter so in proportion to your life it
kind of would have happened at the same
time yeah i mean i don't know that just
sex for its own sake is good i think
there is a problem with touch i talk
about touching the book i think that a
world without touch is like a part of
the inhuman you know technocratic world
um
and that's a bad thing but there are
lots of different kinds of touch and i
think if you live in a hyper sexualized
culture or an over sexualized culture
it's a mistake to think that all touches
is necessarily sexual you know whereas
if you live in a more
you know a culture that is more into
embracing and kissing and stroking and
just being affectionate and all these
different hundreds of different meanings
of touch most of which are not sexual
you know that's a a more beautiful world
you know so it's not against physicality
but i think
you know i think we need to ask the
question about the sexual revolution as
many people are doing like was this
actually liberating i think it's been
disastrous actually in loads of ways um
particularly for women and children you
know i think the unleashing of desire
particularly when it hits the political
realm is is absolutely horrific i think
this stuff should be um privatized you
know that we shouldn't have this kind of
idea that all desires are good and you
know the expression of desire is good
like repression is useful like we need
repression right it's uh
it's important otherwise we wouldn't
sort of i don't know make beautiful art
apart from anything there's so many
pieces to that uh we we did a great
interview with mary eberstad about this
very issue um about the sexual
revolution some of the problems that has
caused mary harrington no mary eberstadt
oh he's mary episode uh she is a writer
she wrote a book called the sexual do
you remember the title
oh
something about the sexual revolution
she's wonderful she's very
basically brilliant it's about how the
sexual revolution created
the massive rise in single parenthood
and all the ensuing consequences all the
way through to the [ __ ] that we talk
about every day which is you know people
with pink hair running around tearing
down
everything you know what i mean
um but look we've run out of time so uh
before we ask our last question kids can
you please start having sex because
francis is very concerned
uh but nina it's been a real pleasure no
i think we barely touch the surface in
this conversation really of of
what are actually very important
conversations you know one of the things
i've always found very strange about the
society we live in is
somehow we've got to a point where men
and women who through their entire
history have had to work together to
survive barely survive together and
they've had to do everything to work
together to just to just
survive have enough food for them and
their children to to pass on their genes
suddenly we've got to a position where
these two groups of people who've had to
work together their entire history
suddenly are antagonistic i just think
it's nonsense yeah i agree
i think men and women are fundamentally
cooperative right yeah the differences
between us are complementary they're not
oppositional in that way
but
that's where we are these very basic
things need to be said so i'm really
glad we've had you on and it's great
that your book is out finally uh it's a
pleasure having you on the show and
we've just got one more question for you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
i don't know i feel like we've we've
discussed all the questions we shouldn't
be talking about um
we're not allowed to talk about um
oh i don't know i think magic
tell us more
i i think we need to to imagine the
world re-enchanted and i think we live
in a very disillusioned world in which
we've forgotten all these kind of
powers of of the spirits and energies
and i think we should be thinking more
along those lines that's a very good
point uh on that note we've got a couple
of questions for our supporters only on
locals uh which we'll ask you in a
second but in the meantime uh where can
people get the book when is it out
you'll probably be out by the time this
interview goes out um yes so it's out on
february the 3rd
i recorded the audio book so you can
hear me read it
i guess it's available on kindle it's
published by penguin
and you really work you need to work on
your promotion okay
go to amazon or whatever right sure it's
probably on amazon go to a book seller
exactly great stuff
well done
all right guys thank you so much for
watching we hope you've enjoyed this
fantastic interview it's such a pleasure
to have nina in the studio uh and we
will see you very very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one or a
raw show all of them go out at 7 pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
is there any empirical evidence for
patriarchy
in modern western european society